[Musique]
je voulais éviter de te l'offrir devant
tout le monde c'est un très ancien
calendrier de l'avent j'étais à ta grand
mère elle voulait que ce soit pour toi
je ne t'ai jamais vue sans un coup cris
dans la bouche je m'en dire non aux
cookies 2010 un très joyeux noël
josh hill est devenu terriblement beau
gosse on est juste à me moquer tu as
voyagé à travers le monde à prendre des
photos à sortir avec des gens sympas
j'étais clarous gers et 24 jours de
supplices comme toi je vais avoir le
courage de réaliser mes rêves
à ton avis qu'est-ce qui se passerait si
tu te lances et je me poserai moins de
questions sur mon avenir
alors sait-on venoix c'est mon voeu de
tous les jours
[Musique]
des bottes cpo que j'avais des bottes et
tu m'as en faire des bottes
c'est dingue non je crois que ce
calendrier est magique c'est sûr c'était
un sapin de noël miniatures et au cours
de la journée
la voiture a heurté un sapin c'est ma
faute le vendeur de sapins m'avait
conseillé de prendre des tendeurs je me
disais bien tout à l'heure que ça
sentait le sapin
c'était sa grand père ce calendrier
c'est juste un calendrier
[Musique]
ab je sais que c'est à la dernière
minute je pourrais vous venir
aujourd'hui pour une séance
vous dit quelque chose c'est vous qui
avez assassiné mon sapin avec votre
voiture est venue bien rendez vous avec
taille ce soir
il ya ce gars je crois que de toi le
gars moi je suis l'ami c'est pas de bol
ça
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ma grand-mère était certaine qu'il avait
des pouvoirs magiques elle disait qu'il
nous avait réunis
[Musique]
waouh
l'ouvrier bizarre il a pris 10 quoi je
sais pas j'ai décidé de pas regarder
aujourd'hui stratégie intéressante
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]